alright well thank you so much Leah for
that introduction and thanks in
particular for inviting me to speak
today I was really delighted to get to
come and speak to this audience being a
part of Numb focus is really a great
project to see all the work that goes on
in the open source scientific software
community data carpentry we are also a
sponsored project of them focus so we're
a part of this ecosystem but we don't
have as many opportunities to interact
with some of the developers of these
open source projects or the people who
are using them in industry settings most
of our focus is in the is in the
research community so I'm going to
becoming a little bit from the research
community perspective here but what I'm
talking about applies in the context of
industry research government because
that we've really seen dramatic changes
in the production and availability of
data that impacts all of us here today
in particular but in the communities
that we work with so the title of my
talk is empowering people by
democratizing data skills so who provide
science will advance or I will be
compiled in there we go okay so this is
an exciting time to be doing work and
research you know I think we talk a lot
about the challenges that we face every
day but this is really exciting the
types of data that we're generating now
and the types of things that we can do
are unheard of even ten years ago
there's so much potential for the work
that we can do the questions that we can
ask so data production is no longer the
bottleneck right we're producing the big
data 3v I know there's a fourth V
sometimes right the variety of data that
we're producing so all these different
types from all of these different
settings instruments the volume of data
that we're collecting so the amount that
we're getting you know just even
terror-byte size image files
and then the velocity of data so this
isn't something that the research
community sees as frequently but I know
that you're probably dealing with as you
get millisecond type information back
from websites so this kind of data is is
pervasive and we aren't limited in our
ability to collect this data anymore but
however with this great opportunity of
data comes a lot of frustration so
called as data pane people are excited
about the potential that the data has
but when they go to sit down to work
with it there may be a little bit angry
or sad or want to further computer
through the window and so the question
and I think what a lot of us here are
trying to make that easier to make that
process of working with data thinking
about data more accessible easier more
exciting and less sad and anger
producing so we talked about you know
the work that we're doing here and I
think a lot of you and a lot of people
in the scientific community a work in
scientific software development and so
the idea here right is that this data
exists and we're trying to make it
accessible to people by writing tools
for them right and this is fantastic
right we need these tools but more
importantly than these tools we need the
people we need the people that are going
to use these tools that are going to
turn the data into knowledge and into
insight so I've story this is so when I
was a professor at Michigan State I had
a colleague that had worked been working
on a particular fungal species his
entire career 40 years so he started
working with this organism when all that
they could do was they could observe its
behavior its morphology they made a lot
of progress just for wearing out what
this organism can do the conditions
under which it could live he went on
then to be able to do single gene
studies very painstaking
work to pull a particular gene out of
this organism to try and study what it
does to look for mutations and now he
had contracted with a company that was
going to sequence the entire genome he
was beyond thrilled right he'd been
working with this organism his whole
career and now he was going to have the
entire genome in his head were all of
these hypotheses that he wanted to test
things that he was going to look forward
to generate new hypotheses so this what
this could do for his work and the
things that he'd been thinking about his
whole career was so exciting to him so a
few weeks later um he whacks into my
office holding a hard drive and he says
now what so he knew where he wanted to
go with this data but when he got it
back from a sequencing center he didn't
even know where to start it wasn't that
he didn't know how to use a particular
tool is that he didn't know how to think
about this data or how to get started
working with this data and this barrier
for him was insurmountable so he has
people in his lab who potentially also
are interested in this problems which
they are but so the question that I want
to help address and not that I want to
talk about today is how we can help with
the now what how we can help people who
are excited about the questions that
they have get started working with their
data so the software and the tools allow
us to turn data into information but
it's the people that are going to turn
that information into knowledge into
discoveries into insight by putting the
data skills and the perspectives in the
hands of people who have the questions
we allow them to follow their curiosity
and capture their passion and expert
knowledge so the idea I want to put in
front of us is that we unleash the
potential of data by empowering people
who better to answer these questions
and the people who have them if this
researcher if this research her hands
his data over to me says here you
analyzed the data yeah I might have the
technical skills to be able to process
the genomic data but it's not
necessarily going to be at the top of my
to-do list right I don't necessarily
know a lot about this fungal genome um I
also lack the expert knowledge as I'm
doing this work I might miss an
important detail about assembling this
genome that has biological relevance
that if this person we're looking at it
would know was wrong so I'm missing not
only the excitement and then the
enthusiasm for this project but I'm also
potentially not getting it right and so
this handing off of data that people
care about to other people who don't
care about it as much and is is a
problem for the field it's a problem for
the researchers for employees for staff
who have these questions that they're
driven to answer I have a similar story
in the marketing world so I have a
friend who works in marketing for a very
big company um and she has does amazing
work there and so they use a CRM and she
was talking to me and she said you know
I wish I could get you know this
information or this information I really
ugly understand that day dynamics of
this market and what people are
responding to and and I told her it well
you know you have all of this
information in your CRM she's yeah but
it only gives me back you know these
like five metrics I said well it's all
in a database it's all back end you can
ask any question you want of this data
and she just looked at me and she's like
how come they never told me that right
like the she's being limited by us
thinking about her workflow her answers
if she's allowed to drive those
questions herself get the data back
herself and she's going to be able to
answer questions improve her work and
um so I told taught her a little bit
about SQL the question of whether they
let her have SQL access to the CRM I'm
not as sure but um so there's just I
think we need to capture that enthusiasm
in our organizations so the question
then becomes how do we scale data skills
and literacy along with data production
right we're good at producing data we're
pretty good at writing tools especially
in san francisco right how do we scale
the people and so it's not just us
saying you guys should all learn these
things I mean certainly maybe there's
some people in that category but it's
it's researchers themselves and I don't
have a similar study and from industry
settings but this is a survey of
resource bioinformatics Australia and so
they took a survey of their community
and they said what is your biggest
bioinformatics difficulties so your your
challenges and dealing with biological
data and so they cited expertise and
training as their biggest challenges in
working with data and then the most
useful thing this organization could do
fifty percent of respondents said offer
training this is more than compute power
or funding I don't think I've ever seen
a plot where funding was this low on the
list and it's because there is funding
to generate data and so what they're
looking for what they need what they're
asking for is training to be able to
work with the data that they're
generating so it's never too early or
too late to start learning so when we
start talking about training you
probably have different images in your
mind about training maybe it goes to k12
maybe undergraduate graduate students
staff right there's a lot of different
levels where we can start this training
initiatives and
they're all good but they all require a
different focus and so what I'm going to
talk about is in the rest of this talk
is a focus on active researchers active
employees so people who already have
jobs who are doing work the advantage of
this population is they're very
motivated so they're like those people
in those initial slide they're motivated
by frustration so when you have those
people show up at your workshops they
really want to learn you don't have to
do a big introduction of you know why
it's important to learn are there like
please teach me are right so um these
people are very excited about this
opportunity to learn and so it's a
really great community to work with on
this sort of learning idea you know I've
been talking a lot about data skills but
i also am going to talking about data
perspectives so it's one thing to have
the skills to work with data but the
other is to understand what data is the
types of things that you can do with it
how to communicate around data how to
organize data and so i would argue that
all of these things are important in
data literacy and that data literacy is
going to be a foundational piece of
being a citizen as we have so much data
opportunities or looking at data driven
government data driven decisions this
kind of data literacy is going to
empower the citizens to make more
informed choices and without that
awareness of what that plot means that
538 puts in front of you you're still
just a consumer of something that is
being produced and not able to evaluate
it effectively so in that realm starting
earlier makes sense as well but we are
where we are so what I say about
training active researchers and
employees is that we're training in the
gaps so active researchers employees are
learning these skills they're learning
them on the job right they're not going
and taking a course somewhere they don't
have time
to go take a course they don't
necessarily have kind of them the energy
the focus to commit to another program
so we need to deliver and develop
training that fits their time and
attention so these are some
possibilities in this space right this
is a big space and there's on lighted
online self-guided tutorials you could
do things like the Coursera courses or
and there's online self-guided short
videos there's online courses in real
time there's workshops on short courses
similar and then there's one on board
one or small group consulting right you
can probably think of some other ways of
training people but there's a variety of
options available when I'm going to talk
about our workshops and why our
workshops effective so workshops are
effective because they're short and
impactful and sort of originally I'll
talk about our workshops in particular
originally called them boot camps
because the idea was you kind of came in
you worked hard you learn to learned a
lot and you left and so they have they
have a big impact in the short period of
time workshops can be hands-on and
interactive so we all know and studies
show that we learn more effectively when
we have a chance to try things out right
it's not just doing things correctly
it's failing and then learning from that
failure and having the chance to do it
again right I'm talking about typos all
the things that that are a process for
learning that we don't really embed in
in our knowledge base until we have the
chance to try it immediate feedback this
is another element that's very important
for learning if we're making mistakes
but we don't have the opportunity to
understand way we're making those
mistakes we're going to need stuck
making that mistake a lot longer and so
having this opportunity for immediate
feedback increases our ability to learn
much more quickly also makes it more
pleasant and less bang your head against
the wall
the focus time so setting aside two days
a day for a workshop your lives are busy
it's hard to allocate time unless
someone puts it on your schedule for you
or you put it on your own schedule right
you all showed up today because you paid
money and put it on your schedule right
would you do the same thing for doing a
self-guided tutorial online you might
but it's a little bit different when
there is an event that you sort of show
up for and decide you're going to spend
your time and attention on and then
finally the shared learning um when
you're in your office running through
something online it's great it
definitely can be self-guided go at your
pace but bringing people together in a
room and that shared learning experience
one is it less you know you're not alone
um I didn't you know oh I didn't know
that I thought everybody knew that
already Oh actually people don't know
that great learning from each other so
an opportunity to talk to your neighbor
to be a teacher if you maybe know a
little bit more than the person next to
you we learn by teaching so helping
others in that environment it also just
makes it a more positive experience and
in the sense that it's a community and
collaborative effort rather than sort of
a solo endeavor of potential frustration
it's group frustration so what I'm going
to talk about in this context I I'm
guessing you thought I would get here in
the end is software and data carpentry
so it's all foreign data carpentry run
workshops and so I'm going to talk a
little bit about what we do how we do it
and kind of some of the lessons that
extend beyond just what we do in our
workshops so our learning objectives
what is it that we're trying to teach
and that we're trying to teach best
practices in software development and
data analysis and management right so
we're not necessarily teaching
everything about data analysis we're
trying to lay the foundation of how to
work effectively with these tools the
delivery approach intensive hands-on
teaching strategies
and in two day workshops these workshops
to our teaching style is informed by
educational pedagogy so we're paying
attention to the education literature in
terms of what's effective in teaching
really that kind of the active learning
model our delivery mechanism and so we
do give these workshops but they're all
based on curriculum and our curriculum
is collaboratively developed lessons
available online for free use and we
train our instructors to teach so we
have an instructor training program that
trains the people who will go out and
teach these workshops and our lessons
are all online cc-by anybody can use
them we use them in our workshops but
you can use them outside of our
workshops as well either for self-guided
learning to teach yourself and we'll
talk a little bit more about that and
finally assessment it's important to
understand how effective our workshops
are being and so we integrate assessment
into our programs pre and post
assessment that's looking at not only
what skills were teaching our people
learning the skills that we're teaching
but our perspectives changing are they
having a better understanding of why
they should write a script because it
makes it reproducible and it's going to
make the them of six months from now
happy when they didn't forget what they
did right so it's not just that they
walk away necessarily knowing about the
deep liar package is that they they walk
away sort of understanding about data
and the value of this approach for
working so when we're assessing when we
do this assessment we're assessing these
kinds of learning outcomes as well as
our content okay so I talked you know
what does that mean when I say hands-on
intensive workshop so workshops they are
usually at a particular University there
for two days and we get everyone sort of
into a room like this and we have an
instructor there at the front of the
room the instructor is
using our materials but they're doing
live coding so they're not just
lecturing from the set of materials we
have examples and they they go through
those examples at the front of the room
and the power of that is that they're
going at a speed that's a little more
relevant to the people in the room the
other is that they make mistakes um and
that's important because there's a lot
of kind of feelings around software and
data that there are these experts that
know everything and never make mistakes
so seeing that person at the front of
the room and make those mistakes seeing
their thought process to how they
correct that mistake that's a really
valuable part of learning as well align
with the instructor at the front of the
room we have helpers and so we usually
try to have about somewhere between like
a five to one and ten to one ratio of
helpers helpers are people who are not
trained instructors they haven't gone
through our instructor training program
and but they're there when someone runs
into trouble that they can come over and
help them so there are part of that
feedback mechanism so if someone can't
get something to run they're not left
struggling on their own the helper comes
over and helps them through that problem
it also lets the course the workshop go
at a little bit different paces because
if someone isn't sort of getting
something or is having some working
through a particular problem they can
get some specific help and so it kind of
keeps everyone together and then finally
a really important element of this is
sticky notes does anyone know who knows
what I'm talking about when I say sticky
notes awesome ok so the where he is and
I say it's awesome is because you don't
know and it's so awesome so um so what
we do in workshops you can see are there
sticking us and there's not sticky notes
in this picture ok so everybody is
sitting like this right and so say
someone runs into a problem what's the
problem with if you run into a problem
raising your hand to your health while
you have a computer can't type right and
you stuck with your hand in the air and
it's actually kind of hard to see
stamps so what we have we have a two
sticky note system we have a red sticky
note in a green sticky note so we have
if you run into problems you put the red
sticky note up on your computer and a
helper will see it and will come over
and help you that's lets you continue to
work while someone comes over to help
you the green sticky note is used for
when we work through exercises so I say
we have kind of this the active learning
or the live coding at the front of the
room so we do sort of we and then me so
we do it together and then the person
doesn't on the own so at the beginning
of an exercise we say okay start this
exercise when you're done with the
exercise put up your green sticky note
so that's also that lets the instructor
know when people are finished with a
problem to keep an eye on the room to
get immediate feedback on how people are
doing so a lot of times you might need
to take longer for an exercise than an
instructor anticipated or you might it
might get through it a little bit more
quickly so it lets the instructor
immediately gauge the room and the speed
that they need to go and see any
challenges that are coming up if they
say half the room that has red sticky
notes right they're going to stop see
what the problem is address it as a
class and then move forward the other
element for that immediate feedback are
minute cards and so these are two days
but we have modules an hour and a half
and then break and then another hour and
a half so at the end of every of those
hour-and-a-half sessions unlike a card
or you could use the sticky notes on one
side you write one thing you learned and
on the other side you write one thing
that you're still confused about and so
the instructors see those they can read
those cards they can see if there are
things that come up often on those cards
or even just a single time and these are
all anonymous so lets people report if
they're having a challenge without
feeling like they're being singled out
and so all of these elements are a part
of this process of really having this
engaged this engaged workshop throughout
in this communication between the
instructors helpers and learners
oh and the most important part so
finally you know I've talked a lot about
you know the room engaging the room the
other is that it's really important to
us that we create a friendly learning
environment again issues around
developing software working with data
computer skills a lot of people are
intimidated and so we don't want that to
be the issue and so we we always try to
talk about the language in terms of
being welcoming but we also have a code
of conduct that's followed for all of
our workshops and in our online spaces
as well look Matt you're in this picture
so the other part of this an outcome are
the instructors so I said that we have
instructors and this is the real
strength and part of the organization
and so we are a non-profit and software
carpentry too and all of our instructors
were volunteers and we have over 900
volunteer instructors on six continents
I'm waiting for Antarctica it's on the
road map for this year I just got a
contact to and so so these are some of
our instructors matt davis who's here in
the audience is one of the instructors
in this picture and one of the early
instructors actually he was my mentor I
think I taught my first workshop Matt
was the lead instructor for that
workshop look what you did so so we have
an instructor training program that
again is a workshop it's two days and
it's where we teach people about
educational pedagogy so the principles
of teaching and what works so they have
kind of a foundational knowledge of what
it is that they need to need to be
communicating and we teach them how to
teach with our materials and so I said
that we have over 900 instructors on six
continents and and we have a partnership
program that that helps get people
through the instructor training we
recently had a call for open instructor
training I think we left that call open
for about three
weeks we had a hundred and fifty people
apply to be instructors so apply to do
something that they are going to
volunteer for right so there's a lot of
demand and to be instructors and so so
why is that why do people want to
volunteer their time to go teach and so
we did a survey of instructors and what
we saw is that one of the main reasons
that people teach is that they have
found these skills valuable and
empowering and they were their work and
they want to share them with others
another is this sense of community so a
lot of people I don't know maybe it's
different here but in an academic
environment a lot of times someone with
computational skills is the lone person
in their lab we call them the pet
bioinformatician and so they feel a
little bit lonely in the sense that they
don't have a community to kind of talk
about you know new skills or and get
feedback and so this really provides a
community of like-minded individuals
thinking about these skills and also how
not only just the skills themselves but
how to use them to advance research or
make discoveries and another really
positive outcome that we've seen from
the instructors this is like this is
kind of one of these unintended
consequences I think of software and
data carpentry as the instructor
community the other is that they learn
new technical things so we use git hub a
lot for our lessons so a lot of people
end up learning github to work with our
lessons they continue to learn new
skills maybe a new package that we're
teaching and they talk to other other
instructors when they go to teach so the
this is a pathway for them to continue
learning they're better communicators
and also our instructors really end up
being advocates for open source
reproducible research all of the things
that sort of we as an organization try
to to represent as being an important
part of the research process so around
the world we have 900 people who
you care about teaching others care
about having them do things in a good
and an effective way and our advocates
for things that we value as researchers
open data open source reproducible work
finally our lessons so I said that all
of them are collaboratively developed
they're all on github and so we break
things down with learning objectives we
use markdown Jekyll so there's templates
and so any kind of modification that
people see maybe they're teaching and
they see that an exercise didn't work
they can put in a pull request file an
issue in this way we have hundreds of
contributors to our lessons and so we're
not just teaching them one time as often
happens in a university course we're
teaching them multiple times every well
hundreds of times every year in this
process of teaching them over and over
again of having community buy-in there's
no single owner of these lessons let
people feel like they can add value to
these lessons and so as I said this has
a nice impact for our workshop but these
lessons are also used without us I can't
remember you know in our google
analytics there's one particular python
module we have that has like thousands
of hits so i don't know who's teaching
that one but we see but i'll hear
sometimes just on twitter or some
attacks to me and says oh we taught your
lessons and I'm like this is fantastic
I've never attacked you before and you
were able to use our lessons without us
even being aware of it right that's the
sign of a good product when no one has
to talk to you to use it right in opens
open source software develop like if you
develop a package and people use it and
never ask you any questions like that's
definitely winning and not not
immediately giving up that doesn't count
not asking questions okay so there's no
big clock on the wall how am i doing
okay I'm good okay 15 thank you okay so
what do we teach I'm star talking about
how we teach the question then is what
do we teach we have two days what r is
it that we teach on so we have to
curriculum do carpentry and software
carpentry with slightly different focus
so dinner carpentry is focused on data
and it's focused on teaching how to
manage and analyze data in an effective
and reproducible way and so the focus is
like this this researcher I talked about
he has data he wants to analyze it right
he's not thinking of himself as a
software developer he's just someone who
has data between him and a question that
he wants to answer the initial focus of
our workshops is for novices so people
with little to no per our computational
experience there are people out there
with more experience but this need at
this novice level is the base of the
pyramid and so extensive that this is
where we're starting with our curriculum
as we go on and we start to meet the
needs of that community will level up
our our materials our materials also our
domain specific by design so we have
materials focused on working with an
individual data set so researchers and
people tend to learn best if they're
learning a new skill in the context of
skills that they already have or a
perspective that they already have and
so if you try and teach a biologist
using business examples it can work but
it's not as engaging and then there's
that extra step of them having to
translate what they just learned into
their domain so we're trying to meet
people where they are and work with the
framework that they have and build the
skills into that framework the other
thing is that then when they leave the
workshop they can immediately go back
and use those skills in their own work
and in our survey results we see that
that this is really true so one of our
questions is
can you immediately apply the skills
that you learned in the workshop and
eighty percent say agree or strongly
agree so people feel like the skills
were teaching our ones that are useful
and that's because we're trying to match
domain and and the data types and the
other is that there are different data
types and different domains so we focus
starting with ecology where it's just
sort of tabular data rows and columns
it's a survey of small mammals in a
desert ecosystem but we also have
developed lessons working in genomics so
that's specifically working with the
genomic data type very different set of
skills different set of perspectives
different set of background knowledge we
also worked with me on the National
Earth Observatory number to develop
materials for working with geospatial
data they are generating huge amounts of
geospatial data many people are again
that's a specific data type and we're
going to be working with our open site
and to develop lessons on working with
api's in some of these contacts other
ones we kind of have on the roadmap
working with astronomy Social Sciences
libraries so there's the man's by these
particular groups and this tailoring to
their specific question gets them in the
door and then more productive when they
when they leave so what are some of the
modules so we're teaching the
foundational skills that will let them
do more specific work so we're not
teaching a specific analysis we're not
teaching a statistical approach and what
we're teaching our what are the skills
that you need to have before you start
to do the statistics so for data
carpentry for the our ecology we teach
data organization and spreadsheets my am
I saying there I'm waiting for this to
take hold is anything is possible if
only you structure your data yeah you're
going to bumper stickers no
okay so the idea of having good data to
start how to structure your data so that
a computer can use it rather than a
person and we talk about data cleaning
with open refine and we know that data
cleaning data organization is one of the
big steps and working with data we teach
our for data analysis and visualization
again focused on the data so we teach
the deep ire in ggplot packages rather
than as focused on base are and then we
teach SQ all for data management in
genomics most of the programs a
bioinformatics programs are at the
command line so we teach the command
line we teach actually all of our that
whole workshop on amazon instances and
and so we teach working in the cloud we
teach automating a workflow so we teach
shell scripting so those are the skills
that working with genomic data are
important to have no matter what
bioinformatics programs are using and so
we really are trying to focus on these
answer that what now question what are
the first steps where do you need to
start with the skills and perspectives
to go on to do the more specific things
that you read about in the papers
software carpentry um so software
carpentry was first it was founded about
ten years ago by Greg Wilson and he was
working with a lot of people doing
research software development and he saw
what a terrible job they were doing and
not necessarily they were doing a
terrible job although that was part of
it but he saw how ineffective it was
right they didn't know about things like
version control or writing functions
right so it was ineffective it was prone
to error and so he set out to change the
state of research software and over a
many year period of time and for a while
he was sort of a lone voice in the room
as he started to recruit more
instructors like math and now it's more
broadly recognized the value of good
software development skills in research
offer in any software you guys all use
version control right
right okay so so it's focused on better
software development packages practices
or writing software for analysis script
so it's not constrained to just like I'm
writing a software package I'm a
software developer right um these
lessons are domain agnostic because
software development practices don't
have sort of a specific underlying data
type so these lessons and they teach the
command line and and github and our or
Python Oh data carpenter we also teach
our or Python and so these lessons are
sort of focused on programming and and
sort of the whole ecosystem around that
okay so um our outcomes instructor
outcomes and community I've talked a
little bit about these learner outcomes
so learner outcomes things that people
report and so some of it is that they
can immediately apply the skills that
they learned in their own work another
is that and they felt the workshop was
worthwhile worth their time so ninety to
ninety-five percent of them strongly
agree or agree that the workshop was
worth their time which is pretty amazing
because to get people in a room for two
days who are busy to them value that
time that they spent is really great and
we're seeing increased learning people
are reporting that they learn the skills
that were teaching but we're also seeing
a shift in those perspectives we ask a
question at the beginning is it
important to use scripts to make
workshop to make your work reproducible
and the question the answer to that at
the beginning versus the end where
people are seeing the value of script
for their own work and for making and
refer reproducibility and the
reproducibility that we sort of preaches
not like reproducibility for the good of
all other that's important but for you
for the you of six months from now who
doesn't remember what you did and the
current new is terrible at answering
email right so learner outcomes have
been very positive instructor outcomes
I've spoken about this a little bit and
the instructor community really gaining
and giving value by empowering people
with the skills they have
learned and finally community and so
instructors are a big community a big
part of this process the learners in the
workshops as I said we've run and this
year alone I think over 100 workshops
and there's 40 people in each one of
those workshops so we're increasing the
community of people who are thinking
about software and data they're learning
from each other this is building a
community of practice that's important
okay so sort of in summary um you know
we see this community of people who are
active and engaged who if given the
skills and perspectives can pursue their
own curiosity can pursue their own
vision and when we take away that
opportunity when we're not t giving
people these skills and perspectives
we're losing that curiosity we're losing
that expert knowledge losing that
passion that people are bringing to
their own problem if we want to make
these discoveries we have to let all the
people who have this are driven to
answer these to let them answer their
own questions the impact that we can
have by empowering people to do their
own work is going to be much broader
than us doing all the work for people
will never be as passionate about things
as people are we won't bring the same
perspective the way we're going to make
discoveries make advancements turn data
into knowledge into insight into
changing important societal at problems
is to be able to give the people
invested in those problems the ability
to do their own work and so we need
opportunities to teach and train in
those gaps and there are different
challenges and opportunities but we're
trying to enable people to form their
own communities and do their own
learning and training so what can you do
obviously maybe you could become an
instructor although we just closed that
instructor training but but things that
you can do if you see value in this you
can support training within your
organization where you are now not just
for your data scientist but for everyone
on your team
increased communication so one of the
outcomes right of training is that
you're moving the conversation further
along you can start talking people know
what github is or people will know how
to think about data so you're advancing
that conversation that you're having
with your whole team further down the
road making it more substitute more
engaging you can support training
efforts for people before they get to
your organization wouldn't it be super
awesome that people came to your
organization with these skills and
perspectives already think about the
social scientist that knows everything
about social science now coming in with
the ability to think and work with data
good documentation of your software
right let's other people may be beyond
your initial use case for your for your
software use that and enabling power
tools for also not doing the thing of
like with the marketing example just
giving them the five answers and letting
people have access to sort of those
power tools that are going to let them
do curiosity-driven a development so I
want to just do a couple of knowledge
meant so over nine hundred volunteers
well why they teach and develop lessons
this is the core of our organization we
couldn't do anything without these
people they're an amazing group I am so
fortunate to get to work with these
people every day Greg Wilson founded
software carpentry and so he put this
whole collaborative lesson development
workshops this whole strategy for
collaborative teaching collaborative
lesson development a community of
learners in place this really had a big
impact the steering committees of
software and data carpentry so we are
nonprofits were guided by steering
committees that help set strategy do a
lot of the day-to-day stuff as the
people who volunteered organize this
conference or you know there's a lot of
work that goes into this and finally our
staffs Jonah duxelles the executive
director of software carpentry Greg
Wilson who's now focused on instructor
training Aaron Becker or associate
director who is here today and manisha
sahni who's our workshop coordinator and
our newest employee Kerry Jordan he's
been working on assessment so that's our
whole staff and finally funding sources
Alfred P sloan Foundation funded initial
work on software carpentry data
carpentry is 42
by the data driven discovery initiative
of the Gordon and Betty Moore Foundation
on the National Science Foundation give
us some early support for the data
carpentry work so I will take any
questions thank you